[Music]
there have been some allegations and and
Mitt Romney candidate Mitt Romney has
has has said yes he's confessed that he
did bully some kids when he was in high
school I thought he said it didn't
remember it I was pretty sure that he
said if I did some things I apologize I
may have I that's what I that was my
interpretation first he said he didn't
remember it that I said that it's so
weird for Mitt Romney to flip-flop like
that that's probably the first time he's
ever done that he's a wall of granite I
guess people came forward and said that
in high school he he and some friends
weld the kid down I mean Washington Post
ran the story and they and they had five
witnesses five kids who were there who's
and they all by the way these are the
kids were part of his gang MIT MIT
Romney led this gang what what kind of
gang would Mitt Romney the argyles
very funny fellas but what I see is even
then Mitt Romney a leader so he and his
gang told down this kid who they thought
was gay and had long blonde hair this is
you know when long hair was an issue and
forcibly cut it off and when this issue
first arose I thought well you know I
never hold anybody responsible what they
did when they were teenagers because I
remember stupid things I did yes however
I gotta say there's a difference between
just doing something stupid that hurts
yourself
I did a lot of those you probably did a
lot of those not a blonde because you're
a comedian yes and then doing something
that hurts somebody somebody else yeah
that's a little different I mean like I
remember when I was 13 years old I
wanted to go into New York City by
myself I'd never done that we lived in
the suburbs in New Jersey so the Port
Authority you're familiar with it yes I
am you used to work there I've slept in
the Port Authority before you became
famous yes that's right you service
services no my name is but anyway it's a
giant building it's a bus station
between 40th and 42nd Street my mother
said to me okay finally I'll let you go
in the city go to the bus stop in
Westwood New Jersey wait for the bus
that says 41st Street Port Authority
well a bus came by and it said 42nd
Street Port Authority I let it go
and then another bus came by 42nd Street
before I let it go because you see it
was the same Port Authority but it just
didn't say 41st Street yes never mind
the point is I was a dumb kid yeah but
but it didn't hurt anybody else
yeah but as far as this bullying you
know this made me think of the Michael
Jackson situation because you know he
was accused of being a child molester
we'll never know because he's gone but
even his worst accuser never said that
he did anything like actually have sex
with him it was grabby grabby under the
covers which is terribly wrong however
when I was 12 years old I was beaten on
the playground
just like the Mitt Romney thing I was
held down and somebody just punched me
in the face while other kids watched and
if I could go back to 1968 and trade
that experience for being gently
masturbated by a pop star well bill
Frankie Valli could jerk me off
it in the Union Gap the Allman
Brothers in time Marvin Gaye it's your
lucky day we have a time machine bill
we're gonna send you back there with a
video camera